I talk sometimes about how people assume
that like the big debates in Wikipedia
or the the sort of arguments are between
the party of the left and the party the
right and I say no it's actually the
party of the kind and thoughtful and the
party of the jerks is really is really
it I mean left and right like yeah bring
me somebody I disagree with politically
as long as they're thoughtful kind we're
gonna have a you know a real discussion
I I give an example of
um our article on abortion
so you know if you can bring together a
kind and thoughtful Catholic priest and
a kind and thoughtful Planned Parenthood
activist
and they're gonna work together on the
Oracle on abortion
uh that can be a really great thing if
they're both kind and thoughtful like
that's the important part they're never
going to agree on the topic but they
will understand okay like Wikipedia is
not going to take aside but Wikipedia is
going to explain what the debate is
about and we're going to try to
characterize it fairly and it turns out
like you're kind and thoughtful people
even if they're quite ideological like a
Catholic priest is generally going to be
quite ideological on the subject of
abortion
but they can grapple with ideas and they
can discuss and they they may feel very
proud of the entry at the end of the day
not because they suppress the other
side's views but because they think the
case has been stated very well that
other people can come to understand it
and if you're highly ideological you
assume I think naturally if people
understood as much about this as I do
they'll probably agree with me you may
be wrong about that but that's often the
case so so that's where you know that's
what I think we need to encourage more
of in society generally is is grappling
with ideas in a really
um
in a thoughtful way so is it possible if
the majority of volunteers editors of
Wikipedia
really dislike Donald Trump
are they still able to write an article
that empathizes with the perspective of
four time at least a very large
percentage in the United States that
were supporters of Donald Trump and to
have a full broad representation of him
as a human being him is a political
leader him as a set of policies promised
and implemented all that kind of stuff
yeah I think so
um and I think if you read the article
it's pretty good
um and I think a piece of that is within
our community
uh if people have the the self-awareness
to understand so I personally
wouldn't go and edit the entry on Donald
Trump I get emotional about it and I'm
like I'm not good at this and if I tried
to do it I would fail I wouldn't be a
good wikipedian so it's better if I just
step back and let people who are more
dispassionate on this topic edit it
whereas there are other topics that are
incredibly emotional to some people
where I can I can actually do quite well
like I'm gonna be okay maybe
um we were discussing earlier the
efficacy of masks I'm like oh I think
that's an interesting problem and I
don't know the answer but I can help
kind of catalog what's the best evidence
and so on I'm not going to get upset I'm
not going to get angry I'm able to be a
good wikipedian so I think that's
important and I do think though in in a
related framework that the composition
of the community is really important uh
not because Wikipedia is or should be a
Battleground but because blind spots
like maybe I don't even realize what's
biased if I'm if I'm particularly of a
certain point of view and I've never
thought much about it so one of the
things we we focus on a lot the
Wikipedia volunteers are we don't know
the exact number but let's say 80
percent plus male
and there are a certain demographic they
tend to be college educated heavier on
Tech Geeks than not you know etc etc so
it it there is a demographic to the
community and that's pretty much Global
I mean somebody said to me once why is
it only white men who edit Wikipedia and
I said you've obviously not met the
Japanese Wikipedia Community it's kind
of a joke because the broader principle
still stands who had its Japanese
Wikipedia a bunch of geeky men right and
women as well so we do have women in the
community and that's very important but
we do think okay you know what that does
lead to some problems it leads to some
content issues simply because people
write more about what they know and what
they're interested in
um they'll tend to be dismissive of
things as being unimportant if it's not
something that they personally have an
interest in
um I you know I like the example as a
parent I would say our entries on early
childhood development probably aren't as
good as they should be because a lot of
the Wikipedia volunteers and actually
we're getting older the Wikipedia so the
demographic has changed a bit but you
know it's like if you've if you've got a
bunch of 25 year old Tech geek dudes
um who don't have kids they're just not
going to be interested in early
childhood development and if they tried
to write about it they probably wouldn't
do a good job because they don't know
anything about it and somebody did a
look at our entries on on novelists
who've won a major literary prize and
they looked at the male novelist versus
the female and the male novelist had
longer and higher quality entries and
why is that well it's not because
because I know
hundreds of wikipedians it's not because
these are a bunch of
biased sexist men who are like books by
women are not important it's like no
actually there is a uh a gender kind of
breakdown of readership there are books
like hard science fiction is a classic
example hard science fiction mostly read
by men other types of novels more read
by women and if we don't have women in
the community then these award-winning
clearly important novelists may have
less coverage and not because anybody
consciously thinks uh we don't like what
a book by Maya Angelou like who cares
she's a poet like that's not interesting
no but just because well people write
what they know they write what they're
interested in it so we do think
diversity in the community is really
important and that's one area where I do
think it's really clear but I can also
say you know what actually that also
applies in the political sphere like to
say actually we do want kind and
thoughtful uh Catholic priests kind and
thoughtful conservatives kind and
thoughtful Libertarians kind and
thoughtful marxists you know to come in
but the key is the kind and thoughtful
piece so when people sometimes come to
Wikipedia outraged by some
you know dramatic thing that's happened
on Twitter they come to Wikipedia with a
chip on their shoulder ready to do
battle and it just doesn't work out very
well you know and there's tribes in
general where I think there's a
responsibility on the larger group to be
even Kinder and more welcoming to the
smaller group yeah we think that's
really important and so you know
oftentimes uh people come in and you
know there's a lot when I talk about
Community Health one of the aspects of
that that we do think about a lot I
think about a lot is
not about politics it's just like how
are we treating newcomers to the
community and so I can tell you what our
ideals are what our philosophy is
um but do we live up to that so you know
the ideal is you come to Wikipedia you
know we have uh rules like one of our
fundamental rules is ignore all rules
which is partly written that way because
it piques people's attention like what
what the hell kind of rule is that you
know but basically says look don't get
nervous and depressed about a bunch of
you know what's the formatting of your
footnote right so you shouldn't come to
Wikipedia add a link and then get banned
or yelled at because it's not the right
format
uh instead somebody should go oh hey ah
Thanks for for helping but you know
here's the link to how to format uh you
know if you want to keep going you might
want to learn how to format a footnote
um and and to be friendly and to be open
and to say oh right oh you're new and
you clearly don't know everything about
Wikipedia
and you know sometimes in any community
that can be quite hard so people come in
and they've got a great big idea and
they're going to propose this to the
Wikipedia community and they have no
idea that's basically a perennial
discussion we've had seven thousand
times before
and so then ideally you would say to the
person oh yeah great thanks like a lot
of people have and here's where we got
to and here's the nuanced conversation
we've had about that in the past that I
think you'll find interesting and
sometimes people are just like oh God
another one you know who's come in with
this idea which doesn't work and they
don't understand why I can lose patience
but you shouldn't and that's kind of
human you know but I think it just does
require really thinking you know uh in a
in a
self-aware manner of like oh I was once
a newbie actually we do have we have a
great I just did an interview with the
uh
uh Emily Temple Woods who she was
Wikipedia of the year she's just like a
great well-known wikipedian and I
interviewed her for my book and she told
me something I never knew apparently
it's not secret like she didn't reveal
it to me but is that when she started
at Wikipedia she was a vandal she came
in and vandalized Wikipedia and then
basically what happened was she'd done
some sort of uh vandalized a couple of
Articles and then somebody popped up on
a talk page and said hey like why are
you doing this like we're trying to make
an encyclopedia here and this wasn't
very kind yeah and she felt so bad
she's like oh right I didn't really
think of it that way she just was coming
in as she was like 13 years old
combative and you know like having fun
and trolling a bit and then she's like
oh actually oh I see your point and
became a great wikipedian so that's the
ideal really is that you don't just go
throw a block [__] off you go hey you
know like what what gives you know which
is I think uh the way
we tend to treat things in real life you
know if you've got somebody who's doing
something obnoxious in your friend group
you'd probably go hey like really
I I don't know if you've noticed but I
think this person is actually quite hurt
that you keep making that joke about
them and then they usually go oh you
know what I didn't I thought that was
okay I didn't and then they stop or they
keep it up and then everybody goes well
you're the [__]
well it yeah I mean that's just an
example that gives me Faith in humanity
that uh that we're all capable and um
wanting to be kind to each other and in
general this the fact that there's a
small group of volunteers
they're able to contribute so much to
the organization The Collection uh the
uh the discussion of all of human
knowledge is so it makes me so grateful
to be a part of this whole human project
I that's one of the reasons I love
Wikipedia it gives me Faith in humanity
no I I once was
um
at uh Wikipedia is our annual conference
and people come from all around the
world like really active volunteers
I was at the dinner we were in Egypt at
wikimani in Alexandria at the sort of
closing dinner or whatever and a friend
of mine came and sat at the table and
she's sort of been in the movement more
broadly Creative Commons she's not
really Wikipedia she'd come to the
conference because she's into Creative
Commons and all that
so we have dinner and it just turned out
I sat down at the table with most of the
members of the English language
arbitration committee and there are a
bunch of very sweet
wikipedians and as we left the table I
said to her it's really like I still
find this kind of sense of Amazement
like we just had dinner with some of the
most powerful people in English language
media because they're the people who are
like the final court of appeal in
English Wikipedia and thank goodness
they're not media Moguls right they're
just a bunch of Geeks Who are just like
well liked in the community because
they're kind and they're thoughtful and
they really you know sort of think about
things I was like this is great
it's like the degree that Geeks
run the best aspect of human
civilization brings me joy in all
aspects and this is Extreme programming
like Linux like programmers in all like
people that kind of specialize in a
thing
and they don't really get caught up in
into the mess of the bickering of of uh
Society they just kind of do their thing
yeah and they value the craftsmanship of
it yeah the confidence of it if you if
you've never heard of this or looked
into it you'll enjoy it I read something
recently that I didn't even know about
but like
the the the fundamental like time zones
and and they change from time to time
you know sometimes a country will pass
daylight savings or move it by a week
whatever there's a file
uh that's done all you know sort of Unix
based computers and basically all
computers end up using this file it's
the official time zone file but why is
it official it's just this one guy yeah
it's like this guy and a group a
community around him and basically
something something weird happened
and it broke something because he was on
vacation and I'm just like isn't that
wild right that you would think I mean
first of all most people never even
think about like how do computers know
about time zones
um well they know because they just use
this file which tells all the time zones
and and which dates they change and all
of that but there's this one guy and he
doesn't get paid for it it's just he's
like you know with all the billions of
people on the planet he sort of put his
hand up and goes yo I'll take care of
the time zones you know and there's a
lot a lot a lot of programmers listening
to this right now with PTSD about time
zones and then there uh I mean there's
on top of this one guy there's other
libraries the different programming
languages that help manage the time
zones for you but still there's just
within those there's it's amazing just
the packages the libraries how few
people build oh yeah out of their own
love for building for creating for
community and all of that yeah it's uh I
honestly don't want to interfere with
the natural habitat of the geek like
when you spot them in the wild you just
want to be like yeah well careful yeah
that thing no I treasured I met a guy
many years ago
um lovely really sweet guy and he's
running a bot on English Wikipedia
that I thought wow that's actually super
clever what he had done is
his bot was like spell checking but
rather than simple spell checking what
he had done is create a database of
words that are commonly mistaken for
other words they're spelled wrong so I
can't even give an example
and so the word is people often spell it
wrong but no spell checker catches it
because it is another word
and so what he did is he wrote a bot
that looks for these words and then
checks the sentence around it for
certain keywords so in in some context
uh
this isn't correct but buoy and boy
people sometimes type Boi when they mean
b-o-u-y so if he sees the word boy be a
y in an article he would look in the
context and see is this a nautical
reference and if it was he didn't auto
correct he just would flag it up to
himself to go oh check this one out and
that's not a great example but he had
thousands of examples and I was like
that's amazing like I would have never
thought to do that and I'm glad that
somebody did and that's also part of the
openness of the system and also I think
being a charity being you know this idea
of like actually this is a gift to the
world uh that makes someone go oh oh
well I'll put my hand up I see a little
piece of things that I can make better
because I'm a good programmer and I can
write this script to do this thing and
I'll find it fun
amazing